we're already a little ways into the
month of December 2015 so it's time for
another monthly update video which I
talked about what went on in November
and what we've got coming up in December
and also a little bit about some things
that are coming up in in January with
the new year as well so as always I want
to begin by mentioning three big things
sort of either going on or on the
horizon one of them is that were
knee-deep in a stoicism class that's
focused particularly on Epictetus as
discourses it's an open access course so
if you're interested in joining in about
90 students actually rolled right now
you can do so I'll talk a little bit
more about that give the the November
and December part to other things the
second one is that we spent quite a bit
of time over the last month locating
talks with local libraries here in
Greater Milwaukee area we have about 20
talks for the the coming year lined up
so that's pretty exciting including 112
lecture series one every month one
quarterly series and the number of other
talks that will be giving at various
places you can always see those in the
Facebook or Google+ events and then
another big thing on the horizon coming
up in January as well is two classes
with a plan up so if you're interested a
lot of people say hey I'd love to take a
class with dr. Sandler this is an
opportunity to do so for college credit
me and fairly inexpensively I'll talk
more about that in the December part so
what went on during the month of
november well November kicked off as
you'll remember with stoic Week 2015 an
international celebration of all things
that was stoicism related and so I took
part in that and partly by producing a
video series and also by a hosting an
event here in Milwaukee
some business lounge we had about 10
people come which was good because we
were actually competing against a major
Milwaukee event that I had known about a
speaker for all that the library was
hosting and I talked about four
components to to the happy life you can
see the video if you're interested in
that I'll link to it below I also did
another free half hour Hagel Q&A google
hangout for the general public I've
committed to doing those monthly as part
of the half hour Hagel series once I
reached a certain level with my my
patreon supporters courses I finished on
my barest world views and values two
sections of that course online in the
month of november i was very happy to be
be done with that those a lot of work
and i started the new global Center for
Advanced Studies Epictetus class which
is an open-access class so that means
that it's not for credits for personal
enrichment and anybody can sign up for
it anywhere in the world what I do in
the course is I if you've ever taken any
sort of courses with me you know that I
provide not only lecture videos and
pages that are sort of like little blog
entries on the stuff but also handouts I
create discussion forums that we engage
in we hold sessions every week video
conferencing sessions I've actually
staggered two on each Saturday so that
we can get viewers and participants from
all over the world like I said we have
about 90 people i think enrolled at this
point in time although i might be off
might be under estimating it right now
and it's going pretty well so we started
that in november i didn't get much
blogging done in november something I
hoped I would do and I didn't get much
academic writing done in part because I
didn't have this area set up I really am
a creature of habit I need to have desk
I need to have you know my books
available to me and so
this now setup is going to free me up
for getting back to that sort of work I
did do a lot of unpacking and moving
things around and you know that sort of
sort of stuff so you know it's not as if
I was just sitting back and taking you
to eat the whole time although when I
don't get to the writing it does kind of
kind of feel like that another huge
thing for us here is that I have joined
a team of people that are involved with
this approach and company called
priority thinking which does executive
coaching ethics training all be also be
developing curriculum for them they are
people who really have a vision in terms
of philosophy and it's connections with
leadership and business I really like
what I've seen it went out there for 42
days got to meet the whole team and see
how things work and now you know have a
good footing for doing that I'm really
excited about that so that's going to be
taking a good portion of my time and
attention as well videos I did quite a
lot of video shooting in the month of
November I shot six half hour Hagel
videos which I released on schedule
that's kind of a big achievement given
that each of these videos is like at
least you know five hours worth of work
I finished up with the play-doh core
concept videos from that symposium
classic truck back in August I finally
released the last of those and I started
releasing some of the Epictetus videos
from the class everybody who's in the
class gets to see the videos as soon as
I've got them finished and uploaded
everybody else i'll be releasing that
bit by bit over over time i also had
something really cool happen in a month
of november as well i got asked to join
the stoicism today t become part of the
project so you know there's been a long
conversation about that and i'm really
happy to be in with that bunch they're
pretty you know serious researcher
and people who know how to do philosophy
in a popular practical in public way so
I'm really happy to be connected with
them and that's yeah that's some really
great stuff so a month of December what
have we got coming up well just one
event because I'm kind of laying low and
taking it easy getting ready for the
beginning of the year when we're having
a lot of talks coming up and a lot of
other stuff doing it I'm just doing one
event which is well I sheptock two
events Tom Richie's AP european history
prep hang out he come Richie if you
don't know who he is as a video channel
he does some really interesting videos
on history I like him a lot because he
does good history of ideas he's pretty
self effacing but he you know so he's a
guy who actually knows quite a lot and I
really like his work so he asked me to
come on and do another Q&A session as an
expert this time talking about the
Enlightenment and the Scientific
Revolution and them whole you know 17th
to 18th century era so that is going to
be this coming Monday which is let's say
today is the fourth so we're talking
about the seventh look for the event
I've got it linked here in the
description of the video I'll also have
another half hour Hagel Q&A session for
December open to the public anything
Hagel related bring it in any questions
that you've got and I will tackle them
that's going to be a little bit later in
the month they haven't yet determined
the date but I will be soon so look for
that as well courses so I've got this
this global Center for Advanced Studies
open access epictetus is discourses
class underway we are just finishing up
with the second week of material which
is booked to we're doing for books and
so
if you're interested in doing the class
you can still jump in and get a lot of
benefit out of it all the materials are
in there in the site i'll put the link
to that it will be you know available
for those who are interested in it I've
got to play no classes coming up in
January like I said and player no is
actually partnering with Burlington
College so there's going to be some
regular college students in there and
then they'll I think be quite a few
other people taking the course aren't
you know affiliated with the college but
I want to take a course just with me
specifically so the two courses are
going to be existentialism which is a
repeat of the existentialism course that
I did last spring which went quite well
I'm still developing new resources for
that so if you've ever wanted to delve
into that material you know that's the
time to do it the course is going to
cost five hundred dollars which is very
cheap for for a course that's 12 weeks
and you know you get all that material
I'm also doing an ethics course ethics
you know it's called ethics moral
theories and applications and the reason
why called it that is we're going to be
reading classic texts you know like
Plato Aristotle con mil also some
contemporary people like you know the
ethics of care people like Virginia held
Alastair McIntyre you know will read
quite a few other people in the course
of that and we're going to learn the
theories the classic you know moral
theories and then we're going to do a
lot of application work so that you come
away from it being able to say well this
is how this would play itself evidence
what you need to look for in that so
very excited of course 1 i've been
teaching for many years from marist
college now converting to a course for a
player note all that is coming up in
January so you know stay tuned into that
I'll be shooting some videos to talk
about that later this month I'm also
working on some some curriculum
materials for
some presentations on anger I hope to do
some more blog writing this month
something I didn't get to the last month
hopefully you know I can get to all of
my blogs I want to do some academic
writing as well on our cell and handsome
get some conference papers that need to
be polished up and sent out kind of
tired of sitting on them and so that I
can get to the next important academic
project videos I'm hopefully going to
get to to shoot the planned six half
hour Hagel videos for the month we'll
see how that pans out you know
everything gets a little bit tricky
around the holidays because you know get
into a big time crunch and there's
events to go to and that's or thing but
hopefully I'll get that done I've been
shooting a ton of Epictetus core concept
videos I've got about another 20 or so
more to shoot this month that i'll be
releasing over over the course of the
month not all of 20 but but quite a few
of them I've got an unboxing video that
I've got coming up for you that you'll
see come coming up fairly soon I'll tell
you exactly what it's about because I
wanted to be a bit of a surprise and
then we'll see what else I can get to as
far as video production I'm not sure
what else i will be doing if there's an
opportunity to do something cool i will
able certainly do that but again a lot
of it as a matter of time so that's
what's going on in december you know a
lot of really fun stuff i'm going to be
working out with my nose to the
grindstone until it's time to totally
relax shortly before the Christmas
holiday begins and yeah that's that so
have a great month and you know if
you're interested in European history or
interested Hagel by all means come to
the online events they're free they're
open to the public if you've got an
interest in epictetus join in the
epictetus class and stay tuned for what
we've got coming up in
in the coming year